today we're answering a long waited and
requested video by some of you guys i'd
love to see a video about study tips and
how you studying mets please share more
of how you actually study which
resources you use for your how can you
manage all the medical information
without forgetting them i replied to
these comments and promised that i would
do a video about it so this is it and
these are the timestamps if you want to
skip to a specific part of the video
hello if you're new here i'm zayha and
i'm a fourth year medical student
studying in the uk so through these
three years of medical school that i
have completed i have changed the way i
studied a fair amount of times it's okay
to change your study method and discover
what works best for you i'm doing this
video so you can actually learn from my
mistakes and start one step ahead and
this would be the guide i'd want if i
could go to the day i started med school
so that i could start using these study
methods from day one
recording voice notes this is the most
underrating study method ever in my
opinion but it's my favorite one my
auditory intelligence is a lot more
dominant than my visual intelligence i
find it easier to learn and remember
information through listening i found
that out through my own trialing and
error and also i took an intelligence
test when i was in primary school which
my school offered to all their students
at the time that's why i do voice notes
these recordings include facts that
comes up the most in questions and also
sometimes if there is a rhyme or a silly
story that helps me remember that
information or learn that fact then i
add those into the voice recordings as
well here's a snippet of a recording i
took last year this was on oncology so
cancer medicine
breast cancer tumor marker most
important one that came up it's
ca153 three looks like breasts pair of
breasts basically i do these voice notes
on my iphone on voice memos app and when
i listen to it to save time i choose
skip silence and i increase the playback
speed to two times or four times and the
biggest advantage to voice notes is that
you can listen to it wherever and while
you do other stuff so you don't have to
focus on it and read like you would for
visual notes i usually listen to it when
i do my skincare before i go to sleep or
when i'm on the bus on my way to
placement it's actually extra helpful if
you get carsick like me when you read
stuff on the bus because with voice
notes you don't have that issue it
doesn't cause car sickness and you can
listen to it when you exercise or
wherever and whenever you want it's
amazing it's my favorite one
do you not buy textbooks i know this
might sound controversial and maybe
you're used to using textbooks and
highlighting them when you were at
school while you were preparing for your
a levels or any university entrance
exams but save your money on that
because most medical schools and
universities actually provide you a free
library account in which there are
electronic and physical versions of any
medical book you would need and that is
if you would need any to be honest i'm
in my fourth year of medical school and
i don't remember the last time i use my
library account to look up something in
a medical book most medics actually save
their money on those textbooks and use
it for their subscription of question
banks which have their own textbooks
which also brings us to our next point
subscribing to question banks this
depends on how your medical school tests
your knowledge so whether they do short
answer exam questions or multiple choice
exam questions and most of the time like
99 of the time that is multiple choice
exam questions i know that through my
own experience from my own medical
school but also from my other friends
who go to different medical schools so
for that reason i've subscribed to two
different question banks which have
their own online textbooks which are
past med and past tests for each of them
i paid 25 pound yearly subscription fee
there are also the question banks that i
know some of my other medic friends use
such as a popular one is quizlet in the
online textbooks of those question banks
you find information about the diseases
that you learn so everything starting
from symptom of a disease to management
of a disease and if you get a question
wrong they have the explanation of the
answers just below the question as well
which is very helpful and what i'm going
to say now is a cliche i know but it's
true the more you do practice questions
the more you see different styles of
questions it will stick better to your
head and you'll actually learn to apply
that medical knowledge into questions
because you might know a medical fact
and if the question asks you that fact
in a simple way you'd get it right
medical school exams they ask you that
fact in such a weird way in questions it
literally feels like a puzzle and you
don't even realize that's what they're
asking that's why it's important to get
used to different styles of questions
for example they usually give you a
symptom of a disease and ask you to
identify that disease through the
symptoms and then ask you the management
of that so it's like double question in
one so they won't straightaway give you
the disease and ask you the management
of that that's too simple
my next point is note taking is a waste
of time but not voice notes i don't use
paper notebooks or take notes anymore
i've been there before i literally made
my own textbook which looks like a work
of art but i realized once i stopped
that and use that time to practice
questions and focus on only high-yield
testable information i scored a lot
higher in exams because i had so much
more time to focus on what i actually
needed to focus it can be scary at the
start and you can get fomo when you see
your other medic friend having all that
pages and pages of study notes but
actually this is the most time effective
decision i've ever made and i stand by
that i know it can feel tempting to
write everything down and make it your
own make it pretty i know it's a big
change but i'd like to challenge you to
stop writing your notes down use that
time to do practice questions and if you
want to read notes use notes that is
already made for you for example from
the textbooks in question banks
watching lectures can be useless i
usually don't watch lectures in medical
school anymore guys because i don't find
them super helpful there were times that
i would do pre-reading before lectures
and go through the lecture content ahead
of time i did do that in the first two
years of medical school but i don't do
that anymore there's no time to do that
and i realize it's not worth my time
anymore i first started watching lecture
recordings and two-time speed and now i
completely stopped watching them because
with the time that i watch lecture
recordings i can do practice questions
and i realize lectures do not really
help me increase my exam score in the
first two years of med school all i did
was watching lectures over and over
again and writing notes from the
powerpoints and my scores went as good
as it is right now because it just took
so much time and in the end i realized
it's just not worth that time sometimes
but rarely they can be helpful that is
only for you to put the knowledge into
concepts for example if the teaching
professor is talking about a patient
that they treated themselves and how
they did it then it sticks better with
real life stories but you can make an
information stick to your head by
testing yourself as well it's a quicker
way to do it than watching an hour long
lecture but you know you be the judge of
that yourself and see if it's a good use
of your time
and finally the last point is thank you
cards making anki cards
guys i started recording this video at
seven a.m in the morning and now it's
half past one i think
yeah it's half past one if there are
light changes and stuff in between clips
you know why so i said writing notes is
a waste of time for me but making anki
cards is an easy and effective way to
write a sentence or two and make a
question out of it usually how i make
anki cards is that i split my laptop
screen into two i have the anki app on
one side and pass med on the other to
keep the anky card to minimum i only
make cards if i get a question wrong or
on the most testable information to
remember that i make a question out of
it typically whichever blog that we're
in at med school at the time for example
let's say pediatrics i would do
questions specifically on pediatrics
block on the question bank then i would
make anki cards simultaneously i have a
specific tag for each blog like cardio
respiratory urology as you can see on
the screen then ideally i review cards
every day so i don't have any do cards
left by the end of the day obviously
this has not been the case since i
started my summer holidays but i'm
hoping to catch up on all of them before
the start of the next academic year and
also organize my anki cards as well
some extra resources for you guys there
are usually links to videos about that
disease on the side of the questions on
past med but if there isn't any then i
go on youtube and watch a video on it
just to get a concept of that
information and actually understand it i
especially like osmosis and zero to
finals just to supplement my
understanding or i use electronic
textbook of clinical medicine by clark
and kumar so i hope you found this
useful please consider subscribing i'd
be so happy to have you here until next
time take care of yourself and i'll see
in the next one bye